welcome to episode 2 of food flight
today we're making Taco Yaki and taking
our taste buds straight to
Japan the last time I was in Japan I was
walking around Osaka with my friends and
we were on one Mission get some
mindblowing taco Yaki these octopus
balls originated in Osaka and the aroma
walking through their streets while
skilled vendors swiftly flip the perfect
spheres is a memory I'm going to have to
replay in my head while making Taco Yaki
from home the Savory batter the bright
Touch of Ginger the succulent octopus
paired with the Umar from the sauces and
dancing Bonito flakes it tastes like I'm
right back in Osaka